is there any chance
that he ends up in tampa bay with you
guys next year
69 chance
yeah a 69 chance
where are you getting that number from
can i ask
that's just you asked if there's a
chance i'll give you a number
all right look do you think he can see
he has another year in him
yeah you do be back we'll be back he'll
be back
there's gronk on brand asked whether or
not he thinks julian edelman will be a
buccaneer in 2021 only gronk would say
there's a 69 percent chance his second
response about alderman emerging from
retirement more
unequivocal than 69 it sounded more like
99.999
shireen this messes with the first thing
i thought yesterday when i saw that
edelman had been released and even after
watching that video that video is not
binding i still remember watching the
press conference when brett favre bald
and squalled and
unretired three times after that nothing
prevents a guy from coming back as of
right now julian edelman says i was
gonna play until the wheels came off the
wheel came off well between now and
november or december
they can put the wheel back on that's
what wheels do they come off they get
put back on you get a hammer you bang it
back into place and i think that's what
julian edelman is going to think about
doing try to do
and
ultracynical view
i checked with the league since he's
been cut he won't be tested under the
ped policy he can go use whatever he was
using when he got busted three years ago
and i feel comfortable saying this
because he did get busted for peds do
what you have to do take what you have
to take get yourself back to the point
where your knees in good shape cycle off
show up get tested be clean play for the
buccaneers pursue what for him would be
super bowl number four i i i
am going to be surprised if that doesn't
happen not not the ped stuff i that that
let's just i'm just i'm just
saying that he could if he wants to i'm
going to be surprised if we don't see
julian edelman back especially after
hearing what gronk had to say
first mike when i'm watching the gronk
video the first thing that came to my
mind
was we've talked a lot about the number
changes right going to single digits i
wish the nfl would just open it up
because you know what number that rob
gronkowski is going to pick to wear
right he's going to wear 69 if he would
get that opportunity of course he
doesn't have that opportunity isn't
going to get that opportunity but i
could see him wanting that jersey number
but
to edelman yeah mike there there's a
possibility that he's going to come back
and play for the buccaneers i think
there's a good possibility if that knee
can get healed enough to get him back on
the field i just feel that and the key
was that he got released he's not on the
retired list he's released he can go do
what he wants to do he played six games
one start this past season with the bad
knee and and had his career best in
yards per catch over 15 yards per catch
this season he could still get field for
six games can he do it for a whole
season it doesn't sound like it but if
you get him back in december he's ready
for the postseason run he knows the
offense hey nothing precludes you from
giving in the playbook right now as a
matter of fact you could let him start
learning the playbook whenever but you
know i could see him coming back and
playing for that postseason run and then
being ready for the postseason and we
know what he does in the postseason
that's when he's been at his best
there's a subtext to all that and i'm
glad you pointed it out because it's
entirely possible that the patriots
pushed him to retire
and he said i don't really want to
retire i don't really want to well we're
going to cut you then so
they cut him he retires it's this big
production i it just doesn't make sense
why wouldn't he just go on the reserve
retired list see doing it this way it
avoids what happened with gronk gronk
went on the reserve retired list and
then the buccaneers had to give up draft
pick compensation to get rob gronkowski
this gives edelman the free and clear
ability to come back if he's healthy
enough and sharing i still can't
reconcile the retirement with the report
last week from karen to region of the
boston herald that it's doubtful that
edelman will be able to play every game
this year that implies that he can play
some
and that fits with this idea you bring
him in late you get him up to speed in
december he's ready to go for the
postseason you can end up having a guy
who helps you win games you know they
added tom brady's equivalent to james
white with geo bernard
their equivalent to julian edelman very
well could be
julian edelman and that's next level of
this buccaneers offense having that guy
who shares a brain with tom brady brady
knows where he's going to be he knows
where brady's going to throw it they
know exactly how to make it work and
i suspect that edelman is going to be
doing everything he can between now and
whenever trying to get that knee to
respond and the only reason again i
mention the fact that he's free and
clear for ped testing is because he's
already been suspended once if he had
never been popped i wouldn't have even
thought of it but this is a way to do
whatever you feel like you have to do
that may not comply with the nfl's ped
policy to get the need to recover
and then you come back
and you have one last ride and you try
to win super bowl number four and walk
off into the sunset as a champion
he has more targets and more catches
than any other receiver from tom brady
in history i mean the two are bffs on
the field there's no doubt about that
brady trust him he knows where he's
gonna be and in big time games in big
time moments as brady said in his
statement yesterday that's the guy he
goes to
i don't think anyone is going to be
surprised if at some point during this
season
julian edelman signs with the tampa
buccaneers if he signs somewhere else i
will say yes i am surprised he signed
anywhere else but i am not going to be
surprised if he returns at some point
this season with the buccaneers mike
april fool's day is an occasion for guys
to under the guise of joking
letting us know what they really want
and julian edelman's april fools day gag
was to
joke that he may be heading for the
buccaneers and i don't think it was
entirely a joke or at all a joke we'll
see how it plays out one more point on
edelman we've talked before about hall
of fame
shereen you have a vote i don't i don't
want one that's my cover for never being
offered one but i don't think he's a
hall of famer i don't think he's done
enough heinz ward's a super bowl mvp
heinz ward's got incredibly greater
statistics regular season a lot of other
guys who are more rewarding but let's
let gronk have the word on it for now
here's more from that tmz walk and talk
with rob gronkowski on whether or not
julian edelman is a hall of famer
a lot of people are asking now that i
know he's done
is he a hall of famer
jules yeah he's he's a patriot hall of
famer for sure a patriot hall of famer
nfl hall of famer uh i definitely think
he has a great possibility
you know the regular season numbers
maybe fall a tad short his postseason
numbers are incredible
right
yeah he's a beast uh and i mean
the numbers just don't show everything
that he brings to the table uh
you know just the attitude and
competitiveness
two quick observations one there's a
greater than 69 percent chance that your
mask isn't going to work if you don't
cover your nose two
gronk tried to be very diplomatic there
he evaded the question oh he's a
patriots hall of famer well what about
the one that people really care about
well he's definitely got a great
possibility
look the regular season numbers aren't
nearly good enough postseason numbers
awesome regular season not even close to
having the discussion shireen and i've
seen the argument made well he was stuck
behind wes welker well if you're a hall
of famer you should be able to run wes
welker to the sideline and you should be
the slot receiver if you're ultimately
going to have a hall of fame career you
don't have a hall of fame career based
upon the fact that guy finally got a
chance to start and he played pretty
well no your full career your full body
of work is what dictates whether or not
you get in and i just think that the the
regular season isn't there especially
given all the receivers nowadays that
have numbers that that dwarf
the julian edelman career numbers
i said for a long time that you don't
use pro bowls as much anymore as an
indicator of whether a guy is a hall of
famer or not because we have normally
yet last year was an aberration because
of cobit normally we have over a hundred
a hundred pro bowlers every single year
because of the super bowl participants
don't play in the pro bowl and because
of injury replacements there's a ton of
guys everybody makes a pro ball
everybody makes multiple pro bowls the
only time you use pro bowls for an
argument for the hall of fame in my
opinion
and what i look for when i'm looking at
hall of famers is if you don't have
enough and when you have zero
pro bowls that tells me that you were
not ever one of the top receivers
normally in your conference sometimes we
didn't do it by conferences when julie
julian edelman played but you are not
even one of the top receivers in your
conference that to me is huge when
you're talking about hall of fame forget
all decade forget all pro because he
wasn't any of that either and then if
you just want to talk about a stats 75th
in career catches 156 ahead of larry
centers barely in yards his 36 career
touchdowns don't even rank in the top
200. he's not a hall of famer he was a
great player in the postseason maybe you
compare him to terrell davis but terrell
davis had was better in the regular
season for a shorter period of time but
terrell davis made all pros made pro
bowls with julian edelman to me he just
wasn't good enough in the regular season
to be considered for the hall of fame
and that's okay he was very good he has
a super bowl mvp he did a lot of great
things he's in the hall of very good and
and that's great not everyone has to go
in the hall of fame it diminishes it
when we talk about guys who don't belong
in there and i don't think he belongs in
there he had a great career that should
be good enough mike
i agree completely and the one thing
that you didn't mention we talked about
it in reference to other guys that ped
black mark on the resume not something
that comes up very often in the room
that's another knock again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports